POLITICAL GAMBIT, TO APPEASE THE
PRESIDENT EVANGELICAL BASE.
>> Mike: GILLIAN TURNER,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE RISE IN THE MIDDLE EAST
BETWEEN IRAN AND THE
UNITED STATES, THE AUTHORIZED
MILITARY STRIKES IN RESPONSE TO
A ROCKET ATTACK FROM THE IRANIAN
BACKED IRAQI MILITIA THAT KILLED
AN AMERICAN CONTRACTOR.
THE MILITARY CALLED IT PRECISION
DEFENSIVE STRIKE, THE MILITIA
SENT AT LEAST 25 FIGHTERS WERE
KILLED AND VOWING AGAINST AMERIC
KILLED AND VOWING AGAINST AMERIA
AND RUSSIA.
FOLLOWING THE PRESIDENT IN
WEST PALM BEACH FOR YOU.
GOOD EVENING, KEVIN.
>> THEY SAID THE DEATH TOLL IS
RISING AND "AMERICAN RAVENS."
>> THIS WAS THE DEFENSIVE ACTION
DESIGNED TO PROTECT AMERICAN
FORCES.
THE CITIZENS AND IRAQ, AND IT
WAS ALL AIMED ALSO AT DETERRING
IRAN.
>> THE SILENCE OF THE STRIKES
RECORDINGS BELIE THE POWER AND
THE PRECISION.
OF WHAT THE MESSAGE TO TEHRAN
WAS CERTAINLY LOUD AND CLEAR.
IF IN ALL FIVE TARGETS IN IRAN
AND SYRIA WERE HIT BY THE U.S. O
AND SYRIA WERE HIT BY THE U.S. N
SUNDAY AND TARGETS CONTROLLED BY
THE AROUND ACT MILITIA AND THE
MEASURE OF REVENGE SAID U.S.
OFFICIALS FOR THE DEATH OF THE
AMERICAN CONTRACTOR WHO WAS
KILLED IN A ROCK ATTACK LAST
WEEK.
>> THEY MADE A FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT
WHERE PRESIDENT OBAMA AND HIS
TEAM TOOK A VERY DIFFERENT
DIRECTION AND PUT AN ENORMOUS
POSITION.
SEEING MILITIAS LIKE THE ONES
THAT CAME AFTER AMERICANS AND
THE IRAQI FACILITY IN IRAQ
YESTERDAY WHERE THEY WERE
AMERICANS WORKING THE COUNTER.
OF >> THREE LOCATIONS IN IRAQ
AND TWO OTHER LOCATIONS WHILE
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON, SUNDAY'S
RETALIATION TARGETED IRANIAN PRO
RETALIATION TARGETED IRANIAN PRI
RETALIATION TARGETED IRANIAN PRS
HAS BEEN NEW CONCERNS OF A
POSSIBLE ESCALATION OF
PROXIMITIES.
IT COULD BE A PROXY WAR WITH
IRAN.
OR WORSE.
>> WE ARE WARNING THE
UNITED STATES AS WE WEREN'T
BEFORE THAT THERE'S A PRESENCE
IS THAT THEY ARE STANDING
AGAINST THE IRAQI PEOPLE AND
THAT THE IRAQI PEOPLE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO CONFRONT THEM WITH ALL
TYPES OF RESISTANCE.
>> THE RESISTANCE THAT SEEN THE
IRANIAN RELY MORE ON CHINA AND
RUSSIA.
IF BOTH OF WHOM RECENTLY
CONDUCTED NAVAL EXERCISES WITH
TEHRAN.
AND CONTINUES TO INSIST THE U.S.
PRESENTS IN THE GULF CREATES
INSECURITY IN THE REGION.
STILL, ITS RELATIONSHIP WITH
IRAN PRESENTS A UNIQUE CHALLENGE
AND ITS RELATIONSHIP FOR THE
UNITED STATES WHILE TEHRAN
REMAINS RELIABLE STRATEGIC
PARTNER AGAINST AMERICAN
INTERESTS IN THE REGION, ITS
UNDENIABLE LINK TO TERRORISM IS
SOMETHING MOSCOW IRONICALLY
PARTNERS WITH THE U.S. TO
FIGHT.
THE CRUCIAL COOPERATIVE THAT
PRESIDENT PRUDEN NOTED OVER THE
WEEKEND THINKING PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN THE PHONE CALL FOR U.S.
ASSISTANCE OF PREVENTING THE
TERROR ATTACK ON RUSSIAN
INTEREST.
BY THE MAYOR PRUDEN ALSO TALKED
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP I
TELL OVER THE WEEKEND AND ONCE
AGAIN, HE INVITED HIM TO TAKE
PART IN THE VICTORY DAY'S
ELEVATIONS COMING UP ON MAY THE
NINTH AND OF COURSE THE
SOVIET UNION'S VICTORY OVER
NAZI GERMANY IN WORLD WAR II AND
THE PRESIDENT FIGURES THAT HE'S